always stay a student the luncheon of
jenga Khan has echoed through history
about burying conquer fueled by
bloodless terrorized in a civilized
world like all reactionary emotional
assessments this could not be more wrong
for not only was jenga's Khan one of the
greatest military minds who ever lived
he was a perpetual student whose
stunning victories were often a result
of his ability to absorb the best
technologies practices and innovations
of each new culture his empire touched
Jenna's Khan was not born a genius he
was the greatest Conqueror the world
ever knew because he was more open to
learning than any other Conqueror has
ever been cons first powerful victories
came from the reorganization of his
military units splitting his soldiers in
the groups of ten this he stole from
neighboring tribes and unknowingly
converted the Mongols to the decimal
system soon enough they're expanding
Empire brought them into contact with
another technology they never
experienced before walled cities in the
Tengu raids Khan first learned the ins
and outs of war against fortified cities
and the strategy is critical to laying
siege and quickly became an expert
litter with the help from Chinese
engineers he taught his soldiers how to
build seat machines that could knock
down city walls in his campaigns cobler
the importance of winning hearts and
minds by working with the scholars and
royal family of delancey conquered khan
was able to hold on to and manage these
territories in ways that most empires
could not afterward in every country or
city he held Khan would call for the
smartest astrologer scribes doctors
thinkers and advisors anyone who could
aid his troops in their efforts his
troops traveled with interrogators and
translators her precisely this purpose
it was a habit that would survive his
death with the Mongols themselves seem
dedicated almost solely to the art of
war they put to good use every craftsman
merchant scholar entertainment cook and
skilled Warford the caiman
attack with the Mongol Empire was
remarkable for its religious freedoms
and most of all for its love of ideas
and convergence of cultures it brought
lemons to China for the first time and
Chinese noodles to the west it spread
virgin carpets German mining technology
French metalworking and Islam the Canon
which revolutionized warfare was said to
be the result in fusion of Chinese
gunpowder Muslim flamethrowers and
European metalwork it was mongold
openness to learning and new ideas that
brought them together as we first
succeed we find ourselves in new
situations facing new problems the
freshly promoted soldier must learn the
art of politics the salesman how to
manage the founder how to delegate the
writer how to edit others the comedian
how to act the chef turned restaurant or
how to run the other side of the house
with too much ego we instinctively think
oh sure I know how to do that it will
all come naturally to me as everything
else has each victory and advancement
that made jenga's khan smarter also
bumped him against new situations he'd
never encountered before with
accomplishment comes a growing pressure
to pretend that we know more than we do
to pretend we already know everything
that's the worry and the risk thinking
that we're set and secure when in
reality understanding and mastery is a
fluid continual process no matter what
you've done up to this point you better
still be a student if you're not still
learning you're already dying learn from
everyone and everything and the people
you beat and the people you dislike even
from your supposed inferiors at every
step and every juncture in life there is
the opportunity to learn and even if the
lesson is purely remedial we must not
let our ego block us from hearing it
again the solution is a straightforward
as it is initially uncomfortable pick up
a book on a topic you know next to
nothing about put yourself in rooms
where you're the least knowledgeable
person that uncomfortable feeling that
defensiveness that you feel when you're
most
deeply held assumptions are challenged
what about subjugating yourself to it
deliberately change your mind change
your surroundings change your
perspective the professional finds
learning and even occasionally being
shown up to be enjoyable they like being
challenged and humbled and engage in
education as an ongoing and endless
process as they say enlightenment is not
permanent it's something we continue to
strive for always stay a student
you
you